How can I sell a hooked business owner within consistent leads, working on the first deal?
Trey, this time of year, it's all in the setup. This time of year, and for anyone listening,
this is what you need to do, at least from now until it gets to be about spring,
you need to make sure not to pigeonhole yourself. What I mean by that is if you call a business
owner, you hook them and you go, hey, I'm going to get you three leads, and then we're going to
talk in three days. Well, guess what? If you don't get three leads, you look like a dumbass.
So what I do at this time of year is I call the business owner, I'm just really open about it.
I'm like, hey, I'm going to get you a couple of leads. It might be in a couple of days,
it might be in a couple, it might be a week, it might be 10 days. I want to get you a couple
really good ones. So let's talk once I do that. And I just leave it at that. That way, I'm not
pigeonholed into it. But typically, the question you're asking, I'm guessing what happened is you
call the business owner, you hook them, and you're like, hey, I'm going to get you a couple of leads,
and you almost made it sound like you're going to have them three leads in three days,
which during the spring, winter, or spring, summer, and fall might be realistic. And it's
like, okay, it's winter. And now the business owner, you're like, shit, is the business
thinking I'm just lying? Does the business owner think I'm full of shit? Whatever.
And so that's the position you're in. So for the specific deal that you're doing,
and maybe you're referencing a deal that you have hooked, you're going to need to just get
gritty, man. You're going to need to go, and what I would do is use some of the Facebook strategies,
go into groups, go into those cities, and search for specific keywords, and see if there's anyone
you can just kind of hustle for. That's what I would do for that specific deal. And if you
have more context that you can share on this thread or DM me, let's talk about it. But I'm
talking about for future deals from now until the spring. Guys, don't pigeonhole yourselves.
Don't make it sound like you're going to get them three leads in 24 hours or in three days
when you don't know. Okay? Keep it open. They don't know that you've given other clients,
they don't know that you gave somebody two months ago three leads in 24 hours or three leads in
three days. They don't have any context. So it's not a big deal. If it's not a big deal to you,
it's not going to be a big deal to them. So if you're talking about a deal you already have hooked,
then my advice would, you're going to have to do some strategies, and you can message me or
comment here or post in the group, because I know a lot of us have talked about these last winter.
But for deals going forward, and this is for everybody, don't pigeonhole yourself in. Do
not pigeonhole yourself in. Do not make it seem like you're going to get three leads in three days.
Just keep it, whatever. Hey, I'm going to get you a couple of leads and then let's talk.
Okay? It might be a couple of days. It might be a week. It might be 10 days. You know how it is
this time of year, Mr. Business Owner. It's Christmas, whatever. I'll get them to you,
then let's talk. Does that sound fair? Awesome. Cool. Boom. You're done. And now if it takes you
10 days, cool. But guess what? If you get the three leads in three days or three leads in five days,
you look like a hero. Okay? So that's my answer.